in this video today we will discuss
about the five possible reasons
as to why godzilla will fight gong and
you know creatures fight and go on their
own separate ways almost every time but
the persistent hunting of kong by
godzilla
has to have an underlying cause these
two tyrants are the last of the alpha
species
the ones that the other titans bow down
to after the death of mothra and
ghidorah and the submission of rodan to
godzilla as king of the monsters
there is only one other monster that
could challenge and be counted as a
rival to the g-man
so in this video we will get into the
possible reasons as to why
they would keep on fighting and fighting
until the other one
or one or the other goes down for the
count so without any further ado
let's get started reason one ancient
rivalry
both of these super species are hinted
in the encrypted scenes of king of the
monsters
and the trailer of godzilla vs kong as
being involved in an
ancient war amongst themselves and there
is still a blood feud that persists as
we can infer by common sense
their past will be covered in the
upcoming movie that will set to light
the valid reasons as to why godzilla
hates kong
khan himself was a young born and yet to
discover his origins and therefore
wouldn't
really have a vendetta against godzilla
which would change
i'm guessing after he goes down the
hollow earth to retrieve the titan
stormbreaker
the pass would play a very important
role in the present and future of both
these titans reason number two the alpha
status
as was seen in king of the monsters
there were many other titans that
exist on the surface of the earth not to
mention the ones in the center of the
world
these titans obey the most powerful of
them all they were awoken by the call of
king ghidorah
and like a hive mind following the
queen's mental state
they went on a path of destruction so
later we saw them heading
to boston and obeying the orcas alpha
command
and then bowing to godzilla over there
but kong was
least bordered and ignored the goals as
was stated in the novelization
so both are alpha titans still and there
is only room for one of them
which means that there is a threat to
godzilla status and he might lose the
allegiance of the other titans since
gong bows to no one and he could sound
an alpha
separate call reason number three
territory as the ancient war between the
two species left an uneasy peace
theoretically it is possible that the
truth was held on conditions that
godzilla and his species
gets the surface and the oceans except
for skull island
and kong species gets the hollow earth
and the island of course
kong lives and resides within skull
island since he was born
so he would not have the slightest clue
as to this arrangement
and maybe as a treaty between the two
warring species that
neither will overstep or cross into the
other's domain therefore in this movie
kong would be seen as an invader
after exiting skull island and again
getting help from humans which means
that he also exerted his alpha status
on godzilla's pets which are us in this
context
reason number 4 bios signature this
theory holds ground and is one of the
more logical reasons
as to why godzilla and kong would fight
so given that the two species already
have an ancient rivalry
apex and mechagodzilla would be more
intertwined with this theory
it could be that apex after creating
mechagodzilla attacks the other titans
and at the same time releases a
biosignature
or an acoustic signature that is eerily
similar to ghidorah
as his remaining head and brain would be
used to power make a godzilla
theoretically so godzilla goes on a hunt
to destroy the source of the signal
and mistakes kong for the new buy
signature of mecha godzilla
since gom was also present alongside
humans apex could use a decoy to trick
godzilla into thinking the brain waves
and bio signature was emitting from the
location of kong and therefore both of
them will fight and at the end
mechagodzilla will come in
and end the game reason 5 kotm
aftermath and the mysterious egg so
during the events of kotm king of the
monsters
mothra sacrificed itself and godzilla
was also nearly dead trying to protect
the world
from monster zero gorm was having none
of that
and in a way abandoned the world to the
three-headed dragon
kong would be viewed by godzilla as
either a rebel or not a protected titan
anymore
also in the end credited saints a
mysterious act was discovered by monarch
whether it is of mothras or godzilla's
origin as yet unknown
but either way godzilla would have
to secure the egg of course and a
youngling inside of it
secure it from humans especially with
them experimenting on mecha godzilla
which would really explain why he has
been attacking monarch and apex bases
all over the world as of searching
desperately for something
and then kong just gets in the way well
the last one seems a little bit
far-fetched but it could be important if
it was combined with the other reasons
we plan to do another video on the
mysterious act the possibility of a
mothra hatching
or godzilla junior perhaps in the end of
the movie
well if you have any other reasons as to
why the nuclear lizard is going all out
against big monkey then i'm all ears
which means comment section so anyway
this brings us to the end of this video
so hit that like button
don't forget to subscribe we are a
stone's throw away from 200k
subscribers and also smash that
notification bell for regular updates
till the next one take care fam